لاننا كنا نتحدث قبل الفاصل عن الجماعات
الدينيه المنتشره في الاوساط التركيه لو
تشرح لنا سبب نفوذ بعض الجماعات داخل
اجهزه الدوله تحديدا خلينا نبدا اول
بجماعه سليمان او سليمان كما كما تسمى في
وزاره الداخليه هل لك فكره عن ااا لديك
فكره عن نفوذها داخل هذه الجهاز
الذي يستمتعونه فيه خاصه في جهه الامنيه
بعد محاكم انقلاب الفاشله عام 2016 فقد
شهدنا عمليات تطهير كبرى
جرت اظن على الجيش التركي وحتى قوات
الشرطه
وبعض اعضاء جماعات يقولن تم استبدالهم
بعظام الجماعات الدينيه اخرى مثلا سليمان
نجيلار ولا شكل بي ان
لديهم نفوذه الكبير اظن الاجهزه الامنيه
في تركيا ولكن عليها نركز علينا الوزاره
تحت السيطره الوزير الحالي سليمان
الوزاره
دينيه فكل من تحتهم همم يصبحون همم اعضاء
من نفسي الجماعه الدينيه ولذلك يبداون
بتوسيعه نفوذه بشكل تدريجي الحكومه
ويمارسون اجانده الحكومه فيسمح لهم بالعمل
بمستوى من استقلاليه شاهدنا ذلك مع وزاره
الداخليه وربما حتى مع وزاره الصحه وبعض
الوزارات الاخرى ايضا والشرطه والامن كمان
وجماعه منزل السعر هل ينطبق عليهم نفس
الفكره
الاولى وكانها قابله للتفسير ولكن نحن
نتحدث عن تغلغل لهذه الجماعات دخيل للبنيه
الوزاريه الحكوميه والمجتماعيه التركيه
ايضا
شكل الجروب
ولكنها ضمن المعارضه ومنذ عام 2002 ضمن
المعارضه لانه حزب العداله والتنميه هو
الذي فاز بعده انتخابات عامه وحافظت على
غالبيته في البرلمان لهذا السبب فن
الجماعات العلمانيه المختلفه حتى وان كانت
صريحه جدا بانتقاداتها فيما خصنا انتهاء
العلمانيه
عامه بفضلي
انا صحيفه يا ساريه هي التي نشرت هذه
القصه وقد ولد
ارتداد الشعبي كبير جدا وكثير الجماعات
العلمانيه وخاصه جماعه النسويه
وقفنا بشكل كبير ضد هذه القضيه وحاول نشر
ما حصل لهذه الطفله الصغيره
والاعلام العلماني هو الذي دفع هذه القصه
والان جماعه العلمانيه التي